[Music]
20:16 was a busy year in science but
before we get to our breakthrough of the
year here are the runners-up proteins
are nature's most powerful and versatile
molecules now chemists have learned to
design novel proteins never before seen
in nature among the first fruits a
potential vaccine against all strains of
the flu and tiny molecular cages that
could ferry drugs around the body a
decade ago
many experts thought a computer could
never defeat the world's best human
players of go it is one of the most
computationally demanding games but this
year artificial intelligence researchers
shocked the experts their program
alphago soundly beat a human go champion
for the first time scientists have
turned Mouse stem cells into fertile
eggs that yielded healthy Mouse pups the
technique works in people it could
revolutionize fertility treatments
astronomers have found an earth-sized
planet orbiting Proxima Centauri a red
dwarf star just over 4 light years away
the planet may be just the right
temperature for water to be a liquid at
its surface scientists have long argued
about how and when Homo sapiens left
Africa this year three teams of
scientists look carefully the genomes of
people living all over the world and
they published three studies that
basically agree most of the ancestors of
people living outside of Africa today
left Africa in one great single wave of
migration
[Music]
these pocket-sized DNA sequencers read
the DNA molecule as it is pulled base by
base through a tiny pore that enables
scientists to do quick on-the-spot
sequencing of pathogens and ecosystems
even in space using techniques that cut
patterns into computer chips researchers
etched a forest of tiny pillars into a
transparent material that enabled them
to create a metal ends it does
everything that a traditional glass lens
does but is thinner than a sheet of
paper and far lighter than glass get set
for even sleeker smartphone cameras and
better virtual reality headsets in
several studies researchers showed that
eliminating worn out cells could make
mice less prone to some diseases of
Aging and it could extend their lives by
20% now human trials are taking aim at
the role of senescence cells and
arthritis in a clever experiment that
involved video and a man in an ape suit
researchers showed that chimps
orangutans and bonobos understand when
another eight holds a false belief that
shows they have theory of mind which
some researchers had thought was unique
to humans
and now the breakthrough of the year
early this year scientists at LIGO
confirmed one of Albert Einstein's
boldest predictions that whirling masses
can shake the very fabric of space-time
generating tiny ripples using
instruments in Louisiana and Washington
state they detected gravitational waves
the discovery opens the door to new ways
of listening to our universe and
thinking about how it works
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]